this video is sponsored by dashlane
quickly and securely fill your passwords
free for 30-days with the link in the
description in the past four decades
natural disasters have killed 60,000
people on average a year this includes
things like earthquakes droughts
epidemics and fires although of course
not all disasters are equally memorable
researchers have found that to get the
same amount of media attention a famine
must kill 38,000 people while a drought
only has to kill 2400 an epidemic 1600
and a volcano eruption just one to catch
the most eyes a catastrophe should be
shocking scary ongoing and most of all
uncertain the corona virus or CoV ID 19
as it's officially known takes all these
boxes and then some the threat is
invisible to the naked eye
deadly foreign and changing every day
here's what we know although the number
has since grown at a hundred and twenty
thousand confirmed cases there were
about four thousand three hundred deaths
giving it an estimated fatality rate of
3.6% significantly lower than SARS at
about nine point five percent or MERS at
34 percent although we also know this
number highly depends on where and who
you are cardiovascular disease high
blood sugar and chronic respiratory
disease for example greatly increase
your chance of death even more
significant is your age the fatality
rate drops to just 0.1 percent for 10 to
19 year olds and remains less than half
a percentage point for anyone under 50
after that the odds rapidly deteriorate
from one point three percent for anyone
in their 50s to three point six percent
for 60s 8% for 70s and fourteen point
eight percent for anyone older the vast
majority about 80 percent of those
infected experience mild to moderate
symptoms most commonly fever dry cough
and/or exhaustion and then recover many
on their own and some without even
knowing
and because these symptoms are so common
the most minor of cases likely aren't
reported to authorities which may make
the fatality rate appear far worse than
it truly is that in fact is also the
biggest challenge a low fatality rate
for the young and healthy makes it very
easy to spread which comes at the
expense of more vulnerable groups the
incubation period is estimated anywhere
from 1 to 14 days if this is true those
infected may spread the virus undetected
most likely by coughs and sneezes
although it can also be found in blood
stool and tears for one or even two
weeks without knowing they have it
scarier than everything we know combined
though is everything we don't it's not
yet understood where it originated who
first contracted it
which animal transmitted its or even how
exactly it began although the first
cases were initially linked to a wuhan
seafood market later analysis has cast
doubt on this theory these large gaps in
our understanding leave considerable
room for anyone to fill as they wish
thus the wide range of reactions
depending on where you look you will
either see warnings that the situation
is far worse than reported and may
eventually kill hundreds of thousands or
please to remain calm and comparisons to
the seasonal flu until recently about
80% of all confirmed cases were located
in mainland China meaning about 80% of
what we know is based on information
provided by that one source which
versions someone is inclined to believe
therefore is largely a litmus test of
how much he or she trusts China there's
little doubt that once its leadership
was committed China acted incredibly
quickly making decisions that would be
layered with bureaucracy elsewhere
famously China seized the spotlight as
an opportunity to demonstrate its
political effectiveness on the world
stage
swiftly converting University's
convention centers and schools into
makeshift hospitals according to a New
York Times estimate over 700 million
Chinese have been simultaneously
quarantined
a feat that requires an unthinkable
degree of both political and cultural
solidarity its state-owned telecoms
collected travel records of every phone
in the country
enabling checkpoints to quickly deny
access to high-risk individuals in that
same spirit of national brand building
Chinese diplomats have given over 400
media interviews published over 300
articles and the city of Shanghai sent
500,000 face masks to the center of the
South Korean outbreak China has tried to
disassociate itself from the outbreak
suggesting it may have originated
elsewhere it's also repeatedly
congratulated itself for slowing its
spread which it argues would be far
worse if not for its diligent work what
can't be overlooked however is the
phrase once its leadership was committed
too often journalists fall into the trap
of either only celebrating China's
operational efficiency or fixating on
its authoritarian pitfalls clearly the
same top-down system responsible for
building a hospital in ten days
also incentivized local government
officials to suppress crucial early
information about the virus in
prioritized party loyalty above
immediate human suffering it's genuinely
impressive successes exist in the
context of failures like the example of
Wuhan base doctor Li wen Liang on
December 30th over a week before the
first confirmed death Li sent a message
in a private doctor's WeChat group
warning of a new SARS like outbreak just
hours later eight doctors from the group
including Lee were arrested by Wuhan
police for spreading rumors and
disrupting social order as announced by
the Chinese National Health Commission
after being compelled to sign a document
admitting his alleged crimes li
heroically returned to work where he
would contract and die from the very
virus he tried to stop while his story
is particularly tragic it's only made
exceptional by his personal sacrifice
the forces which tried to stop him are
sadly not for every rare example of
bravery there were undoubtedly countless
more scared into silence
and if even doctors must be this devoted
to the party
there's only more reason to doubt
government compiled data if numbers were
misreported outright fabricated or even
just poorly or hastily collected they
could drastically skew global measures
like fatality and infection rate thus
the large discrepancy of these numbers
between countries on March 6th the US
had a reported fatality rate of 5.9
percent while South Korea reported 0.6
what these numbers obscure are the
number of people tested America's number
for example was based on apathetic then
239 identified cases and 14 deaths two
koreas then 6593 and 42 the lesson of
this chart is that the easiest way to
maintain a low infection rate is simply
not to test for it something the US has
thus far excelled at up until recently
making test kits inaccessible to anyone
not exposed to a confirmed case or
having recently traveled to an infected
region South Korea on the other hand had
tested 8,000 people prior to its first
case On January 20th the next week it
would go on to test 82,000 people across
the country by making this process easy
like with drive-thru stations it was
able to screen about 10,000 people every
single day the most dangerous kind of
misinformation therefore aren't crazy
claims about fake cures which are easily
exposed and dispelled but the treating
of reported data as infallible which
creates unnecessary alarm in some places
and a dangerous sense of comfort in
others in truth everything except the
very basics should be viewed with some
degree of skepticism by the time you're
watching this video the situation may
have changed and many of the numbers may
no longer be accurate at the same time
it's important not to panic while it's
true that so much is unknown the
precautions are simple and
straightforward this is the paradox of
the corona virus although the medical
solutions are simple the World Health
Organization recommends washing your
hands with soap and water or an
alcohol-based sanitizer regularly and
not touching your face stopping the
virus is not easy in practice no
government on earth can effectively
manage and guarantee the compliance of
every one of its citizens especially in
democracies where government power is
limited while the virus appears to be
waning domestically in China it's
entered a distinct second phase of
international spread to Italy Iran
France Germany Spain the US and
elsewhere in the absence of the tight
control made impossible at this scale
which countries succeed in containing
their outbreaks largely depends on their
level of public trust a good point of
comparison are the cases of Hong Kong
and Singapore two places with similar
population sizes climates and
international exposure at first glance
Hong Kong would seem to be at far
greater risk with 13 border crossings to
mainland China while Singapore is three
and a half thousand kilometers away even
today in response to the virus three
crossings remain open in Hong Kong while
Singapore became one of the first
countries to deny entry to all PRC
passport holders and anyone who's been
to the mainland in the past 14 days its
government was quick to distribute masks
for for every household whereas Hong
Kong faced shortages during which long
lines formed outside pharmacies for
hours as customers waited for new
shipments in Singapore self employed
quarantine residents and holders of work
passes are given about 70 US dollars a
day along with free medical treatment to
incentivize good behavior those who
break quarantine laws are fined up to
7200 USD and face as much as 6 months of
jail time authorities in Hong Kong on
the other hand began the crisis with
little to no public trust and only lost
more after its slow closing of the
border and failure to procure masks
worse
this often well-deserved distrust
spirals into a self-propelling panic
because Hongkongers didn't believe their
government could or would protect them
the most panicked began hoarding
supplies fearing they might run out
everyone else followed suit in a
dangerous game of musical chairs and
when the music stops
it's most often vulnerable groups like
doctors the disabled and the poor who
lose it's also worth noting however that
Hong Kong's widespread distrust
predisposed its residents to take
matters into their own hands
creating a more vigilant public a more
severe example is Iran where extreme
suspicion of government has resulted in
an outright crisis inescapable by even
the highest levels of authority this
pattern has repeated time and time and
time again anywhere Trust is low the
lesson repeated but never absorbed with
SARS Ebola MERS and now today is that
while the problem is a medical one for
scientists to research and develop
treatments for the suffering is most
often self-inflicted the actions of
people and governments make the
difference between calm and chaos after
the virus is contained its treatment or
vaccine hopefully discovered and the
media moves on to more shocking stories
we must not forget how much was
preventable
otherwise the same forces and incentives
which aggravated the problem will only
remain dormant waiting for the next
outbreak and enabled by our disinterest
like an outbreak your online security is
easy to ignore 99% of the time but when
something happens it's already too late
- Lane is the digital equivalent of
washing your hands it's the simple
solution to keep your passwords and
information safe online because like
another outbreak it's only a question of
when not if another big hack will occur
except it's even better because unlike
washing your hands - Lane saves you time
even if you think you have nothing to
hide or nothing of value online I still
recommend using - Lane because it saves
you time by generating and then filling
in your passwords for you of course
holding your passwords is a big
responsibility and that's why you should
trust - Lane which has been endorsed by
companies like the Wall Street Journal
and featured on the Apple and Google app
stores go to the link in the description
- link com / poly matter pol Y ma TT er
to get a free 30-day trial of -
Premium if you like it use my code poly
matter to get 10% off